[Música]
bienvenidos a cinco minutos con
centenares de niños en el mundo son
reclutados cada día para participar en
conflictos armados justamente este 12 de
febrero se conmemora el día
internacional contra el uso de menores
de edad soldado para hablar de este tema
nos acompaña federal rubio líder en
incidencia de la ong world vision
colombia gracias por estar con nosotros
federal cuál es la radiografía actual
del reclutamiento de niños usados como
carne de cañón en conflictos armados y
cuáles son los países más afectados
muy buenos días muchísimas gracias por
este espacio bueno a los países donde
mayor preocupación se encuentra también
son los países que se encuentran
casualmente en conflicto según la onu
dice que siguen aumentando decenas de
miles de niños y niñas vinculados a las
fuerzas y grupos armados por ejemplo en
el 2019 unificó a 7 mil 747 niños
algunos de tan sólo 6 años entre ellos
el 90% fueron utilizados por actores no
estatales
en 46 estados todavía aún reclutan niños
y niñas menores de 18 años entonces es
un tema que todavía sigue generando
alarmas a nivel mundial lo mismo ahorita
a través de la pandemia pues se ha
acrecentado este flagelo hacia niños y
niños
fedra distintas organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos de los niños
como unicef trabajan para evitar que los
menores sean víctimas de las guerras
como soldados usted trabaja en colombia
cuál es la situación en este país que
lleva cuatro años de un proceso de paz
entre el gobierno y la guerrilla la ex
guerrilla de las farc
bueno pues del observatorio de mi
conflicto armado de la cual hico en su
reciente informe relata que durante el
2020 se presentaron por lo menos 79
eventos que afectaron cerca de 222 niños
niños y adolescentes siendo víctimas o
en riesgo de ser usados por causa del
uso reclutamiento por parte de actores
armados también a esta historia del
pueblo en el 2020 en kilos promedio de
23 de alertas tempranas que daban la
persistencia del riesgo de reclutamiento
y utilización de niños niñas y
adolescentes en zonas como antioquia
caquetá cauca chocó meta nariño valle
del cauca y putumayo entonces vemos que
todavía es un flagelo que está que sigue
a pesar de haber firmado ya unos
acuerdos de paz justamente por el
contexto del conflicto en colombia este
país se puede decir que lidera
históricamente la problemática en la
región
es uno de los países que pues están
liderando esta problemática es un país
que lleva más de 50 años viviendo en
temas del conflicto y que formas que se
han tenido acuerdos con algunos grupos
todavía siguen habiendo grupos o
disidencias de los mismos que siguen
captando los niños y niñas para usos
ilegales para el reclutamiento lo siguen
utilizando para sus actividades al
margen de la ley pero hablemos del caso
de las niñas reclutadas como esclavas
sexuales como les brindan atención una
vez que están en libertad
es un tema de acompañamiento y muchas
veces se piensa que el tema del
reclutamiento base a los niños
únicamente pero se ha identificado que
las niñas también son usadas allí están
en riesgo de matrimonios tempranos de
abuso sexual de embarazos a temprana
pero también en temas como encargada de
la cocina de la alimentación de muchas
otras acciones también que les limita su
desarrollo como niños entonces aquí
viene este acompañamiento e identificar
también cuál es el acompañamiento que
requiere cada niño cuando sale de estos
grupos armados porque muchas veces ellas
están en en sus grupos con un tema de
poder hay alguien encima ejerciendo ese
poder entonces como también evitar una
reincidencia evitar proteger a los niños
a los niños para que no vuelvan a
reincidir a vincularse a estos grupos a
que sean reclutados por estos grupos
fedra pues muchas gracias por todo este
análisis por los datos que nos ha
aportado en este día y a ustedes muchas
gracias por su sintonía continúen con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]